en el vídeo anterior dijimos que ciertas
frecuencias de radiación infrarroja y r
pueden provocar que un enlace se estire
imaginemos que este enlace entre el
carbono y el hidrógeno es como un
resorte que cumple con la ley de hook
así que la vibración de estiramiento del
enlace es como la oscilación de un
resorte que tiene una masa en cada
extremo y entonces veamos un poco de
física clásica y de mecánica para
entenderlo mejor aquí tenemos una caja
es una masa m y supongamos que no hay
fricción entre la caja y el piso pero la
caja está unida a la pared por medio de
un resorte entonces si jalamos la caja
hacia la derecha es decir aplicamos una
fuerza en esta dirección
entonces estiraremos el resorte y
moveremos la caja hasta esta posición
suponiendo que movimos la
hasta aquí podemos decir que la
desplazamos una cierta distancia delta x
pero como la caja sentirá una fuerza que
la jala de regreso hacia la izquierda
supongamos que la detenemos para evitar
que se mueva entonces la fuerza que jala
la caja de regreso hacia la izquierda es
la fuerza del resorte ahora de acuerdo a
la ley de hook la fuerza del resorte es
igual a menos k x donde el signo
negativo es la fuerza de restauración es
decir la fuerza que hace que el resorte
regrese a la posición original por otro
lado que es la constante elástica o
constante de fuerza del resorte ésta es
la constante elástica y depende de qué
tan fuerte o débil sea el resorte por
ejemplo si tenemos un resorte muy rígido
el valor de k aumenta pero si tenemos un
resorte muy elástico
el valor de cada disminuye lo escribiré
para un resorte fuerte o rígido el valor
de k aumenta y si tenemos un resorte
débil o muy elástico el valor de cada
disminuye ahora x se refiere al
desplazamiento del resorte a partir de
la posición original
en este caso desplazamos la caja una
distancia delta x entonces si tenemos un
resorte fuerte la caja experimentará más
fuerza hacia la izquierda y de acuerdo a
la ley de hook si aumentamos k
aumentamos la fuerza del resorte
por lo tanto entre más lo estiramos es
decir si aumentamos el valor de delta x
la fuerza del resorte también aumentará
así que la fuerza del resorte es igual a
la masa por la aceleración menos k x
cual a m y la aceleración es la segunda
derivada de la posición podemos escribir
a la aceleración como la segunda
derivada de la posición no voy a entrar
mucho a esto pero podemos resolver la
frecuencia de oscilación del resorte a
partir de este sistema masa resorte
entonces si resolvemos esto nos queda
que la frecuencia de oscilación es igual
a uno entre dos pi por la raíz cuadrada
de k / m
analicemos a qué se refiere la
frecuencia de oscilación si jalamos la
caja hacia la derecha y la detenemos en
esta posición qué pasará cuando la
soltemos bueno la fuerza del resorte
provocará que la caja se mueva en esta
dirección hasta llegar a esta posición
porque el resorte se comprime así que
también hay una fuerza del resorte que
va en esta dirección
pues toda la energía acumulada en la
compresión empujará a la caja y la caja
regresará al centro es decir a la
posición de equilibrio la caja se moverá
hasta llegar a la posición original con
la que empezamos a esto se le conoce
como oscilación y al tiempo en el que
ocurre una oscilación se le conoce como
periodo y se mide en segundos entonces
si tenemos uno entre el periodo esto es
igual a la frecuencia que la podemos
escribir así o así y las unidades nos
quedan como 1 entre segundos entonces la
frecuencia es el número de oscilaciones
por segundo número de oscilaciones
por segundo y que afecta a la frecuencia
bueno la constante elástica del resorte
que afecta a la frecuencia así que al
aumentar el valor de k aumentamos la
frecuencia si tenemos un resorte muy
fuerte la masa oscilará muy rápido lo
escribiré al aumentar k al aumentar la
fuerza del resorte aumenta la frecuencia
y qué pasa si aumentamos la masa bueno
si aumentamos este número éste disminuye
así que al aumentar la masa disminuye la
frecuencia y por lo tanto no tendremos
tantas oscilaciones por segundo porque
la oscilación será más lenta regresemos
a nuestro ejemplo supongamos que por
ahora el carbono se mantiene en la misma
posición pero vamos a jalar al hidrógeno
hacia la derecha para
a estirar el enlace jalamos el hidrógeno
hasta acá así que aplicamos una fuerza
en esta dirección y el hidrógeno siente
una fuerza que lo regresa en esta
dirección esta es la fuerza del resorte
entonces si tenemos un enlace muy fuerte
eso significa que aumentamos el valor de
acá y por lo tanto también aumentamos la
frecuencia de oscilación así que al
soltar al hidrógeno habrá una oscilación
que será muy parecida al sistema que
vimos entonces si aumentamos la fuerza
del resorte aumentamos la frecuencia y
qué pasa si cambiamos la masa por
ejemplo que en lugar de hidrógeno
tuviéramos carbono u oxígeno o algún
elemento que tenga una masa más grande
qué pasa con la frecuencia de oscilación
bueno si aumentamos la masa disminuye la
frecuencia de oscilación así que este es
un buen modelo para poder entenderlo sin
embargo en este caso hablamos únicamente
del movimiento del hidrógeno pero en
realidad cuando hablamos de la vibración
de estiramiento las dos moléculas están
en movimiento analicemos ese caso ahora
tenemos dos masas vamos a generalizar
las aquí tenemos m1 y de este lado
tenemos m2
entonces m1 y m2 son nuestras masas son
dos átomos y como en este caso las dos
masas se mueven necesitamos modificar un
poco la ecuación de frecuencia ya
habíamos visto que la frecuencia de
oscilación es igual a uno entre dos pi
por la raíz cuadrada de k / m
pero como nosotros tenemos dos masas que
se mueven necesitamos usar algo
diferente en m podemos usar algo que se
conoce como masa reducida
lo escribiré la frecuencia es igual a 1
/ 2 pi por la raíz cuadrada de k / m
pero en lugar de escribir m porque esta
es una situación diferente usaremos este
símbolo que representa la masa reducir
la masa reducida es igual a m 1 por m2 /
m 1 + m2 y como estamos hablando de la
masa del núcleo podemos usar la masa
atómica para obtener un valor aproximado
entonces pensemos en el enlace carbono
hidrógeno si tenemos el enlace carbono
hidrógeno m 1 corresponde al carbón y m2
corresponde al hidrógeno
cuál es la masa reducida bueno la masa
reducida es igual a la masa del carbono
que es 12 por la masa atómica del
hidrógeno qué es
entre 12 + 1 usemos la calculadora
tenemos 12 por 1 que es 12 entre 12 más
uno que es 13 esto es igual a cero punto
923 la masa reducida es igual a cero
punto 923 hagamos otro ahora veamos un
enlace carbono carbono la masa reducida
es igual a 12 por 12 entre 12 + 12
entonces 12 por 12 es igual a 144 entre
12 + 12 que es 24 esto es igual a 6 la
más reducida es igual a 6 y que ocurre
con la frecuencia de vibración si
aumentamos la masa reducida bueno
observen que pasamos de una masa
reducida de 0.900 23 a
de 6 entonces al aumentar la masa
reducida si aumentamos este valor
disminuye la frecuencia de vibración por
lo tanto esperaríamos que un enlace
simple carbono carbono tenga una menor
frecuencia de vibración que un enlace
simple carbono hidrógeno ahora veamos
qué pasa cuando tenemos un doble enlace
aquí tenemos un enlace simple carbono
carbón pero que me dicen de un doble
enlace carbono carbono bueno la masa
reducida sigue siendo igual a 6 pero qué
pasa con la constante elástica o
constante de fuerza del resorte
bueno en el caso de un doble enlace
carbono carbono podemos decir que esto
tiene el doble de fuerza que un enlace
simple entonces si la constante elástica
para un enlace simple
para un doble enlace es tosca y al
suponer que un doble enlace es el doble
de fuerte aumentamos el valor de la
constante elástica pero qué pasa con la
frecuencia de vibración al aumentar este
valor también aumenta este así que
aumenta la frecuencia de vibración
tenemos un enlace más fuerte así que lo
más importante a recordar es que los
enlaces fuertes vibran más rápido un
enlace fuerte aumenta el valor de acá y
por lo tanto aumenta la frecuencia de
vibración pero qué ocurre con un átomo
más ligero por ejemplo si tenemos un
átomo más ligero como el hidrógeno
obtenemos una masa reducida más pequeña
así que vibrará más rápido que un átomo
pesado entonces los enlaces fuertes
vibran más rápido al igual que átomos
ligeros por eso es muy útil
saben que los enlaces son como resortes
y estos son dos puntos muy importantes a
tomar en cuenta lo que afecta la
frecuencia de vibración es la fuerza del
enlace y la masa reducida